so Elon musk's response to Kanye West
calling him a half Chinese and generic
genetic hybrid a West who was banned
from Twitter for posting a Nazi symbol
last week branded musk a genetic hybrid
and suggesting that he's a half Chinese
on Instagram on Sunday and a bizarre
rambling post the disgraced star also
took him as former president Barack
Obama referring to an outrageous
conspiracy theory that he is a cologne
of an Egyptian pharaoh I take that as a
compliment musk replied West shared a
screenshot of musk response and claimed
his comments had always been intended to
be complimentary West posted a defensive
tweet on Thursday night then posted a
photo of the topless musk on a yacht
writing let's always remember this is as
my final tweet musk responded to the
image of himself saying that is fine but
replied this is not to West's swastika
tweet so go ahead Adam since you had
some thoughts on this well I mean
we we often consider uh Elon Musk to be
a troll right I mean he's he's very good
at it
um but the way that he was able to take
The High Ground here with Kanye I think
he said this wasn't a very flattering
picture of me and it kind of motivated
me to lose weight yeah right did you did
you see that part yeah so it's crazy
because if you if let's actually go to
the source here Google young Elon Musk
Chinese let's look at the picture right
let's let the story speak for itself so
let's find a good nice picture of a
young Elon Musk and see no not
fabricated where they make him look like
Kim Jong-un not a deep fake let's go to
a young Elon Musk and see if he actually
in fact looks Chinese which you know I
mean you know spoiler alert no he's not
Chinese he's a white guy I actually
tried to sell my mom on this like no he
looks shiny she's like what are you
talking about yeah so the comedian John
Mulaney gave it and actually a very
a funny uh take on a bit about this
years ago he said that basically when he
was young people said that he kind of
looked Chinese familiar with this bit
well uh to what Melanie did Melanie I
got it I might have gone he basically
says when I was young I had this like
silky hair and I had these kind of by
the way John Mulaney is a complete white
guy yeah and he says that all the kids
in school would make fun of him and call
him a China man and he basically says of
all the epithets and the racial epithets
that's just the easiest One China and
man boom and to the it got to the point
here there's John Mulaney looked I guess
Asian in this picture yeah but right
correct just like Elon but he basically
said it got to the point where like he
said nobody is meaner than an eighth
grade boy because they will tell you
like the truth and say the meanest
things about you and
it got to the point where the bullying
was so bad that he uh during a music
appreciation class every time that they
hit the gong everyone in unison would
get up and bow towards him but it just
kind of it just it kind of goes to the
point where it's like clearly this is
not true wow clear this is absurd and to
a deeper level Kanye sing a lot of
absurd crazy ridiculous things and
there's a good percentage of our country
that are like let Kanye talk he's right
he's got some points it's like at what
point can we just recognize that he's
got some serious mental issues going on
right now I think I think we I think the
I mean the majority of us do and it's
just crazy I think we talked about it
Adam we might have I don't remember if
it was you or not but the fact that
obviously he's going through like a
mental situation and he I don't think he
has anybody like we do like if I mess up
if I said some mess up stuff like this
you let your Vinnie just off like you
need to chill out Pat said something Tom
said something he's paying all these
people bro and you can say he'll get yo
his attitude is volatile if you say
something that he doesn't like you're
fired bro you're dumb no he doesn't have
uh yo chill out he has all Yes man he
doesn't have anybody going yo relax you
just lost what two billion dollars how
much more You're Gonna Keep Going how
much more because they're all losing
money bro yeah all his people his team
it's a wrap you can't you know it's bad
when Alex Jones is distancing himself
from you oh my God you are too extreme
that's that's when you know it's over
that's all Jones multiple times
told Kanye well you're not a Nazi
supporter right right buddy right I love
Adam you know you know how I take this
uh Elon Musk response I take the Elon
Musk response that he's done
he's just moving eyes like the cement
stop it like done with Kanye yeah it's
like it's just too much it's a little
too much let's just move on and he's he
he sounds like just the basic customer
service representative saying what he's
supposed to say to just move on and not
create it's almost like he's trying to
help him not react to anything else you
know I said something a couple like not
even a couple weeks ago I think I said
this a week ago where I said Connie I
think it's time for you to take a month
off of social media say no to to all
podcasts including Peabody podcast just
don't do any podcasts for a month just
take a break away from everybody and go
do some thinking everybody's got to do
it pastors do it business owners do it
military leaders do it you know parents
have to do it sometimes relationship you
gotta get away and decide how you're
gonna come back from this because this
is not a good look when you become too
addicted to wanting to get attention you
say stuff and at this point
um it's it's very disturbing is going
through I just think he needs to take a
break from everybody for about a month
and surround yourself with a few people
you love you trust that will not tell
anybody who are willing to privately
call you on your [ __ ] I don't know
if it's going to happen or not but I
think Elon Musk is like and the beauty I
don't even have time and the beauty with
the country is Pat if and you killed it
if he stays the beauty about this
country stay away six months a year come
back fresh I apologize
no this is America everybody comes back
bro everybody that's just jacked up can
couldn't come back if they're genuinely
sorry but he's just every week is just
something every day it's like something
else something else something else like
bro go away for a little while I think
he is is digging the hole deeper and
deeper every time and I fully agree with
Pat but I know you're an odds guy Pat
what are the odds that he actually heeds
your advice and just says you know what
right you're Pat you're right Pat let me
take some time off and cool down for a
little bit I'm putting that at zero
percent there there's two different
things there is accidental there's
intentional decisions we make accidental
is somebody in your family dies you
choose to change you know
Force change is your girl breaks up with
you publicly it's humiliation you have
to change you lose everything you have
to change intentional is very hard to do
force all of us do it okay all of us do
it but intentional is the hardest thing
to ever do and change because you have
to choose to do it and I don't know if
he's intentionally going to change but I
guarantee you he's going to be forced to
change and that guarantee of being
forced to change will be because
something's going to happen to his life
you're going to either see the the kid
coming up to him saying Daddy you got to
stop this is too much I'm getting issues
in school you're making life harder one
of the kids has to say that don't I
don't want to be spending time with you
I want to take a break with you it's
going to drive him insane a parent a
parent who loves their kids and I
believe that this guy loves his kids I
really believe this guy loves his kids
fully and it's not everybody but some
every parent loves their kids no they
don't there's a lot of people that are
deadbeat fathers who step away if they
really love their kids why would they be
away from the kid for nine years so I
really think this guy loves his kids and
I think the the change is going to be
one of his kids I don't know how old how
old is the oldest kid that he has North
Northwest at probably 10 years old I'll
just say nine or ten yeah I mean if Tico
came up to me saying something at that
age he I can't have a serious
conversation with both Dylan and Tico
I really think there's only one person
that can get him to do that it's his
oldest kid I don't know if that's gonna
happen or not he's probably gonna say
Kim's telling you that your mom told you
to say this so it's going to be like
that anyways yeah one last question yeah
your opinion Pat you know a lot of
people are calling him crazy bipolar all
right you know there's a famous phrasing
yeah he's crazy like a fox yeah just
play Devil's Advocate because I'm sure
you're not a fan of what he's doing
if you could go into the mindset of
Kanye West yeah and justify this type of
behavior justify this type of lunacy
as a crazy as a fox type of methodology
what would his intentions let me ask you
a question let me ask you a question let
me let me just simplify it for you it's
very easy for us to sit here and trash
this guy or any of these guys so what is
the most humili you don't need to say
but I want you to go with everybody at
this table what's the most humiliating
thing that ever happened in your life go
there you don't need to say it I'm not
telling you to say it but just go there
we all have it did you kind of figure it
out got it okay now imagine if it's on
every article every news every podcast
every TV channel tell me how you feel
about it okay so actually think about
that right there that's what this guy's
going through a freaking Pete Davidson
took his wife his wife went with him who
is Pete Davidson and the league of Kanye
for contributing to society in the world
I mean Pete Davidson Kanye's the music
he's done the art has created the you
know the not not taking anything away
from Pete but there's a difference in
talent and value to the world right when
so so in his mind he's sitting there
saying my girl left me for that
he's publicly humiliated and he's trying
to recover from that embarrassment but
the approach is taken is is not the
approach I would take so anyways I I
don't uh uh I feel very bad and I don't
like it at all it makes me feel very
uncomfortable and I wish I could talk to
the guy but I don't think he's in a
place that he would be willing to talk
to anybody and take counsel from anybody
I don't think he trust anybody and by
the way for the right reasons she'll go
talk to a 10 year old kid and see what
your 10 year old kid tells you because
that kid loves you
it's your blood so what all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red or
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]